hello everyone my name is anton i'm a
principal software engineer at microsoft
research in cambridge
i would like to give you a whirlwind
tour through the in right toolbox and
show how you can use it to accelerate ai
model research
my colleague michael is afterwards gonna
show you how he has used the inri
toolbox to build models to reconstruct
magnetic resonance images
our team has worked in
ai for cancer radiotherapy for a pretty
long time
so for radiotherapy
doctors need to sit down and draw
contours onto each slice of a large 3d
image like a computer tomography scan
this is shown here on the left
from that the patient's anatomy can be
reconstructed and treatment
can can be planned
now this is a very time consuming task
where doctors often have to sit down for
hours
and we published a clinical study last
year
that showed how a carefully crafted ai
model can actually reduce significantly
the amount of time doctors have to sit
down
to
contour images
and this is a technology that is now
being prepared for rollout across
several hospitals in england
in order to do this study we had to
build like
thousands of ai models and we were not
thinking okay how can we take the
learnings and the infrastructure that we
built
in this project and make them useful in
for more use cases and for a wider
audience
and yeah this motivated really the inri
deep learning toolkit
so
it contains um first of all
all of our own research results the
models that we have been working on and
so forth to make the transparent and
reusable for others
but with this toolbox we'd also like to
enable other organizations to build ai
models faster and follow a follow back
best practices
and in particular also tie in with cloud
computing
and
cloud computing is really a big enabler
here because
massive data sets in particular in
massive
in medical imaging
they do create headaches if you don't
have distributed training available
now
trying to illustrate here how the inride
toolbox comes in
into play with the model development
process
so probably most of you who have built
ai models know that you often start out
with a script that downloads data that
defines the actual model and then it's
running the ever same thing about the
training loop and you write a report
and so forth and then you look at this
report after a couple of training runs
and you see okay maybe i have to tweak
that a little bit and you end up with
maybe a second script and the third
script that is that are all very
repetitive
and if you're not very careful you can
end up with a pretty big mess pretty
quickly
what the inright toolbox does for you
here is that
is that it provides all of the
boilerplate code all of the repetitive
bits in
in model training
so everything that is highlighted in
purple here is coming from the in right
toolbox and you as a researcher you
would only bring in the thing that
really matters to you and that's the
model itself
there are also provisions to
to use automatic hyper parameter tuning
so re-running training for example with
a changed learning rate and this is all
thanks to the
to functionality built into azure
machine learning that's the
azure ml's hyperdrive use
functionality
what i'd like you to remember here is um
that with the inright toolkit you can
take any pie torch lightning model and
run it in azure machine learning or on
your local box so just take the model
itself
pytorch lightning
if you have not used that before is a
super helpful abstraction layer on top
of pi torch which again does away with a
lot of the repetitive boilerplate code
in typical training scripts for deep
learning
with the inri toolbox you don't need to
write any extra code in order to
get full cloud integration with azure
machine learning you get distributed
training without any extra efforts
and you also get model management so in
your code base you will no longer have
a set of scripts
but you will only have a set of models
and you can pick any of them to
for training
how does that look like in practice so
this slide here shows a piece of code of
a model configuration as you would
rightly to put into the inroad toolbox
so we have here
the name of the model that's
also the name of the class
you would have here the name of a folder
in in azure blob storage that specifies
where your data lives
also provisions if you want to run the
same script on your
local gpu machine
and the two critical parts here are
there is one method that returns the
model that you wish to train so that's
something that you would have had to
write anyway
and the second method here is
effectively telling the inroad toolbox
how how it should read data so this
method here needs to return three data
loaders for training test and validation
set
once you take this piece of code and
drop it into the in right toolbox you
can you're ready to go with model
building so you would take the inrai
model building runner you say
model lung and off it goes and it trains
that model
if you now want to do exactly the same
thing in the cloud
all you need to do is add an additional
command line flag
azure ml
and this is now going to take the the
code in your local folder it's going to
package that up send it over to the
cloud and then azure machine learning is
going to give you a gpu virtual machine
it's going to create a conda environment
for you and run your script
so this process here just uploading to
the cloud takes roughly 20 seconds and
then you're good to go and do something
else or you can for example make a
slight tweak submit a run make another
tweak submit your run and then
afterwards you can inspect all your runs
in the azure machine learning portal so
you get full transparency of like all
the runs that you have submitted
recently
you can dig in
and check ok what were actually the
command line arguments that they used
for any given run you get the reference
to which git commit
id you used
the code itself is stored as well
and you can inspect the
console output as training progresses
all of these things are available in the
cloud live
you get easy access to all of the
metrics that your model training writes
there is also support for
viewing everything in tensorboard in the
same wash up
and something that i really like a lot
is with just a couple of mouse clicks so
by going here to edit columns you can
turn this view into a dashboard you can
for example pick the peak to display the
training loss
or other metrics
and then you can immediately see how
your different runs stack up against
each other
all of the
typical operations that you have in
model building are available via command
line options
so for example if you want to now switch
to
distributed training then you just say
number of nodes equals eight and that's
it
you do not need to write any um any
additional code for that
if you want to train the model on it on
a slightly different data set then you
just provide yet another command line
argument you can add notes so that you
can more easily keep track of which run
contains which of your ideas
or modify training parameters
and this really has changed dramatically
how we operate as a team because
all of our team's results are no longer
siloed away in our individual virtual
machines but everything's right there in
the azure machine learning workspace
so we will be able to see immediately
who of us has the best idea to push this
model forward
you get full traceability so if at some
point you need to go back and check okay
this good model what did that actually
do
it's all there the code is there the
data is there
and model deployment with additional
cloud tools is also pretty simple if
you've already trained in the cloud
now this already brings me to my summary
slide so
if you'd like to write less boilerplate
code
for your ai model training then give the
inri toolbox a try
you get
no code cloud integration pretty much
you can also build upon all of the
successful model architectures that we
have used in our work for different
tasks so there is um
image segmentation there are
self-supervised learning there is bits
around a chest x-ray classification and
everything is available with a rather
permissive license
and some of these bits are also now
going to be packaged up into a separate
python package for maybe even easier
reusability
and now with that let me hand over to
michael
hi my name is michael hansen and i would
like to tell you a little bit about what
we've been doing with mri reconstruction
and the inner eye toolbox
i think this is really an example of an
application where the integration with
inner eye gives us easy access to the
scale of the cloud and allows us to work
with some otherwise
very difficult to work with large data
sets and long training runs
so but before i dive into the details of
what we've been doing i thought it might
be worthwhile setting the stage and just
explaining what we mean by uh mri
reconstruction
so mri is not a camera it does not image
the object or the patient directly we
actually get a set of indirect set of
samples about the object that then pass
through a reconstruction procedure and
then produces an image that's
interpreted by a clinician
we're very interested in this process
because if if i leave out some data
if i do an undersampling of the data set
i can create a better patient experience
by creating a shorter scan or maybe a
scan that has less radiation or is less
uncomfortable for the patient
but if i do that and i pass through a
regular reconstruction i'll get an image
that has artifacts in it
which can't be interpreted clinically so
i'm interested in developing procedures
that would allow me to somehow
synthesize the missing data
and allow me to pass through a
reconstruction and then get to an image
that can be interpreted clinically there
are many different ways to work with
these types of procedures but one of the
approaches would of course be to train a
model
to perform this image reconstruction so
that we fill in the missing data and
this is what we've been doing with inner
eye
i want to spend a little bit of time
talking about the data that we work with
in this space because there's very few
available public data sets and we happen
to be used one that's called fast mri so
i'd like to introduce that and explain
how you work with it
in the inner eye toolbox
so the fast mri data set was released by
nyu and facebook a few years ago and has
been used in a number of public
challenges
to develop new algorithms and has really
accelerated the progress it's a really
cool data set contains raw data
from lots of mri scans and the
associated images so i can look at what
a fully sampled reconstruction would
look like and then i can try and
undersample the data and then try
different reconstruction algorithms like
just filling in zeros or other more
conventional techniques and then it
turns out that deep learning based and
algorithms
actually do a very good job of
recovering images that have very good
image quality so this data set is really
great for working to develop these types
of model there's also a source code out
there on github that was released by
facebook and nyu that shows some of the
models that have won some of the early
challenges and allow you to train those
and that's kind of the code and the data
that we've now enabled you to use within
the inner eye framework
one thing about this data set that i
want to call out though is that while it
contains raw data and images
it doesn't actually tell you where the
important bits of those images are so
specifically if there's a lesion or
something clinically relevant in a
certain region of the image we don't
necessarily know where it is
so to allow people to work with this
data set um
in a little bit more focused way we with
permission from nyu we took this fast
mri data set and then we had some
external radiologists actually put
clinical annotations on this so we've
annotated about a thousand knee scans
and about a thousand brain scans
so that we now have bounding boxes
regions of interest where we know that
there's something of clinical relevance
in these images this now allows us as we
go through many different model training
runs in the nri framework to really then
zoom in and see well in the clinically
relevant regions are we able to
faithfully reproduce the lesions that
are in there
and and if not you know what what
artifacts occur and so on so this is
this allows us to work with this new
data set in in a different way and so we
release these labels onto github so if
you're working in the space i recommend
you go take a look at that um at that
repo where we had the annotation so this
now gives you the full pipeline from raw
instrument signals all the way to the
to the clinical readout and allows you
to interrogate various parts of that
pipeline
but i want to focus a little bit more on
how you then work with this
fast mri data within the and models
within the nri framework so there's
really like three different uh three
stages to your work here you have to
prepare the data train the model and
then keep an eye on how that training is
going if you want to get started with
this i recommend going to the nri github
repo and checking out there's a
documentation page specifically for the
fast mri stuff how you get the data and
how you get started so i'll just give
you the highlights here the first stage
is that you sort of have to prep this
data this is a very large data set
terabytes of data and the way that you
get a hold of this data is you go on the
fastmri.org site you sign up and then
you get a list of links to download
but it's actually a very com
laborious process to get all this data
downloaded and organized and so what the
inner eye toolbox now provides is a
simple script you pass all these
download links to it it will set up an
azure data factory pull all the data in
and get it organized in the cloud and be
ready to use just that step alone is
something that will take you quite a
long time if you want to do this on your
local workstation and being able to do
that in an integrated way in the cloud
is really very powerful so then once you
have your data lined up then you go
ahead and train a model and we've done a
few things to make that easy here first
of all the fast mri repo that has some
starting models is now a soft module of
the inner eye toolbox so we have access
to the pi torch lightning modules that
it provides in there and then there are
the configurations that anton mentioned
that you need in order to be able to run
the training and with that i can simply
kick off a training run with a single
command line here running an azure in a
number of nodes and now i'm starting to
get to something where what used to take
hours now takes minutes what used to
take maybe weeks is now down to a day or
so in order to
to train a model so this allows us to go
through a lot of different model
training runs and really
figure out what works and what doesn't
work and since we now have annotations
for this data set we can then really
zoom in and figure out uh how to how do
how does it reproduce clinical lesions
and so on
i want to mention one thing about
monitoring the training as well antoine
mentioned that you can use the azure ml
dashboard to look at metrics and you can
of course do that here as well but i
want to call out that there's the
tensorboard integration is quite
valuable here for the for training these
machines of these imagery construction
models because it also provides a view
of intermediate images
that the models produce so you can
actually see at different stages in the
training what kind of image
reconstructions would this particular
model be able to provide so since this
is a very visual thing sort of evaluate
globally what happens to those things uh
this is quite powerful so the
tensorboard integration is uh is
something that i use a lot when i when i
work with this
so now we've managed to train a model
and we have it so the question is can i
actually use this could i connect this
to a real clinical mri system and we did
a little prototype to investigate this
we used an open source framework called
the gadgetron which is available on
github as well to kind of uh establish a
basic pipeline and then feed the data
into the model that we've been training
within our eyes so the way that this
looks at a high level is you would have
an mri scanner and as it acquires its
data it gets converted on the fly as it
streams out and goes through some
external compute where you have a
pipeline running in this gadgetron
framework it consists of a number of
modules we we can leverage all the
modules for pre-processing organizing
the data and then we can pass the data
through the model that we trained with
inner eye to produce images and we can
even have a model that now detects
lesions based on the annotations that we
did
with the data so that we can actually
take annotated images return them back
onto the
mri scanner as they're being acquired
and do a full end to end integration
this whole pipeline we can package up in
a container and then deploy into an aks
cluster for instance and then have the
scanner connect directly to this so with
this sort of setup we can now manage the
data train models deploy them
and and work with them in a in a real
realistic environment
so just to sum all of this up uh
training these imagery construction
models within our eye is is is
relatively easy uh we have uh
enter and tested and worked with the
fast mri data set and associated sample
code and you can use that directly we
can take these trained models and
connect them to real clinical mri
systems and we've also augmented the
fast mri data set with clinical
annotations that you can download from
github if you want to really dive in and
figure out how these models perform
so that i just want to acknowledge that
a lot of this work that i showed here
was actually performed by by people that
spent some time with us here as as
interns and visiting researchers so i
want to call out their contributions and
and thank them for for coming to
microsoft and spending some time with us
and then thank you for your attention
and call uh your attention to these
links where you can go find out more
about the
inner eye toolbox thank you